c'est pourquoi il est un grand politicien
parce que c'était l'une des plus grandes
réponses que j'ai jamais entendues aimeriez-vous
de beaux combattants Isis tout le monde que vous
voulez des combattants en Syrie nous avons une
quantité énorme de combattants capturés
combattants Isis Coburn Syrie et ils sont
tous sous clé, mais beaucoup d'entre eux
Fred sont venus d'Allemagne, beaucoup d'entre
eux du Royaume-Uni, ils viennent principalement d'Europe et
certains pays sont d'accord.
permettez-moi de dire que
le très grand nombre de combattants que vous
avez sous terre, je trouve juste cela venant
de Syrie d'Irak et les combattants étrangers rouges
venant d'Europe, mais c'est
une infime minorité de l'ordinaire
dans la région et ne vous méprenez pas
votre  le problème numéro un n'est pas
un combattant étranger ce sont les
combattants d'Isis indirectement et vous avez plus
de plus ces combattants utilisent la situation
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi c'est un grand
politicien parce que c'était l'une des
plus grandes réponses que j'ai jamais eues c'est ok
parce que parfois vous  peut avoir une certaine
tentation du côté américain, je ne dis pas
les deux fronts présents, mais pourrait être la
presse pour dire
que c'est la responsabilité européenne. Je suis désolé de dire que nous
avons certains de nos gens, mais si vous ne
regardez pas le  réalité de la situation
que le numéro un pour ne pas être ambigu avec
ce monde c'est pourquoi nous avons commencé à
discuter de nos relations avec la Turquie
mais je pense que toute équité avec la Turquie
avec un livre d'affaires est difficile et à
tout le monde pour la situation
vous